uh take this lollipop you tell us about
that that's this interactive
facebook thing take this lollipop is the
most successful facebook
application of all time now it said over
70 million hits and a commercial
director named jason zada created it
he also created an application which
plays every christmas called elf
yourself
which you may have seen we have little
elves dancing and you put your family
members face on it
so zadah came up with the idea for take
this lollipop it's his baby
he made facebook has a api guidelines
for their applications
and he and his team very creatively
made an application that would do things
facebook never thought it could be done
but all within their guidelines
and so he created this application in
which you give it permission to access
your profile just as you do with any
facebook application suddenly
you're in a dark hallway you're over the
shoulder of a very creepy guy
sweaty grungy bastard and a wife beater
and he's trying to hack into somebody's
facebook profile oh my god he's in whose
profile
and he goes from there he looks at your
friends he's pawing the screen
he's really agitated and then he's
looking up the map to see where you live
and it ends with him driving in a car
coming to get you with your facebook
profile picture taped his dashboard
so i got that role and it helped quite a
bit because essentially it was a two
minute commercial for what i do best on
camera
and it's been very good i'm very
grateful to jason's otter for it
the characters that you do play are you
modeling them
after maybe people you've seen in public
where you imagine their life as a
certain way
or maybe people that you grew up with
where are you finding
this backstory for some of these
characters are you modeling yourself
after people you've known
no no no i suppose i'm not a good enough
actor to do that
um i suppose that i should observe
people more and try to copy them but
karen i don't even know if i really know
how to act i've never been
trained to do it i just know how to
become other people
and some of the time i can do it well
enough so that people say
you are you're really the guy you're
really the redneck
uh you know slashing the mexican's
throat that's a real guy right that's
not an actor i get those comments about
stuff i do
um so i just keep going to my own dark
well which is dark enough to drop
and then with scare tactics they are
crowdfunding
for have they shot the film or we shoot
in
september in the fall oh okay and
whereabouts do you shoot
here in l.a okay thank goodness yeah the
reason that you know i did this east
coast stage career for 13 years and came
here three and a half years ago
and i got really tired of sleeping on
the road because in theater that's where
you make your money on the road
if you're willing to sleep in wichita
one night and then louisiana the next
you can make money
but i wanted to be in a place where i
could practice my craft and sleep in the
same bed
so when it's an la shoot i'm always
really happy
if it's an out of town like i gotta
go to new york next month
and it's a lead role and i'm glad to
have the feature but i'm like
why can't they shoot it in la you know
right
when i was a little girl um i would
write letters to
michael landon and and scott baio and
brook shields and asked them
how do i get into the business did they
write back they did not
unfortunately but um i'm not even sure
if i sent them to the right place
what would you advise somebody coming
here i mean so many people think oh yeah
go to central casting and they sign up
and you see all these bright
happy people from other parts of the
country thinking that this is their
ticket in
what's what's the way to work in this
business
um know who you are and know who you are
on camera
and try to make them the same thing
because the camera
is a great truth detector and i learned
that on stage you can lie all day long
i do musical comedies of all types of
roles but the camera is
right there it's all eyes and you have
to tell them the truth if you lie on
camera you won't be any good and
you're going to work on the camera so
you have to take a real assessment of
yourself
look at yourself on camera if you don't
like what you see
there's probably something in yourself
you don't like because the camera ain't
lying
the camera's the camera is telling the
truth the camera's telling you what you
are and who you are and if you don't
like
you can't oh i'm gonna do a makeover
you'll still be the same damn person on
camera
you've got to accept what the camera
sees if you're going to work on camera
that's what i think camera acting is a
whole different animal than the stage
and i know that sounds kind of nebulous
and people want to hear oh
i need a good agent they'll do it for
you but if you've got that
if you can say what is it that the
camera likes to see me doing
where is that in me and how can i make a
clear channel
for that when i get on set and i'm in
front of a camera it's my friend now
because i know who i
am i know what it wants me to do the
camera's like a lover michael caine said
that
and i find it to be true the camera
knows how it wants you to touch it
if you don't touch it that way it'll go
look at somebody else it's a fickle
lover
so you gotta keep it happy interesting
so what if you see yourself on camera
and you don't like what you see
where do you do that inner work
you have to define what it is and now
crassly this is called your brand
this is what you are i tend to be dark
on camera
i'm somewhat menacing always a little
bit
a little disturbed a little off
something a little strange that's the
way the camera picks me up so
i gotta find that stuff in me am i a
little weird
am i a little offbeat am i a little
messed up am i a little
strange yes acknowledge those parts and
embrace those parts
you just can't lie if you lie and you
try to be a camera actor
unless you have really big breasts and
you're 20 years old you will not be a
success
and then as soon as you're 25 and you
start to get the first wrinkle it's gone
so you know i'm a middle-aged guy i came
to l.a i'm nobody from nowhere
from a stage career that was big on the
east coast but nobody cared about here
so i had to create myself
and to create
what i am on camera and make it who i am
as a person too so this has been really
good for me
it's been a good process i know who i am
and i think that's what acting's about
right
how did you come to know your type i
mean what was it was it a casting
director that pointed it out
when i came to la having done musical
comedy and all sorts of light rolls on
the east coast
my agent at the time sent me out for the
soccer dead rolls
and you know happy soccer dad and for
commercials and you know
it's the acne scars and i i have
there are all types of scientific
studies on what types of faces make you
trust them
and which side don't and i have all the
hallmarks on the face that you don't
trust
the deep set eyes and the uneven texture
and the lengthened face and the nose
i've got all of it
everything about this face says don't
trust me so anyways doing these soccer
dad auditions and this really nice
camera got an audition took me to the
side and he said dude
you're the soccer dad who's going to
kill the team and eat them
he said that's what the camera sees that
is the truth
go dark and the darker you go the more
you will work
change everything that's online about
you to reflect
that brand because that's the truth that
you are on camera
and he was right as soon as i started
doing that
i started working more and working
regularly
were you okay with this evaluation
no not at first that hurt not at first
because i had deluded myself actors are
great
self-deluders and i had deluded myself
into thinking that i was so versatile
that i could do anything
and under the right lights on stage and
under the right makeup
you do get fooled by the applause
because
you can do anything there because it's a
big tableau but the camera again
this is it this is the camera it's right
here there's nothing to hide behind if
you try to
hide it's going to show in your eyes so
um accept the truth or don't worry
i chose to accept the truth the truth of
what i am on camera
i know this all sounds very pretentious
and people might think oh it's just
about you know standing in front of the
camera and finding my light and looking
pretty
and it may be for another actor but it's
not for me this is
the only way that i can work what was
the turning point for you when your
career began to click was it when that
casting director told you
this is your type and you went with that
buzz yeah and how how did that happen i
mean so
then you knew okay this is how to market
myself
what what was it about that that took
you
in a new direction i uh i came into
contact with the person who's not my
manager shortly after that matt jason
and we talked about branding
and i have a marketing background i love
marketing for theater i marketed a lot
of the shows that i was in
and so it clicked it's the same thing
i'm
laundry detergent i'm tied what kind of
tide am i
i got a whole shelf of tide what am i
i'm creepy tied if you wash your clothes
in me
they're going to come out creepy no
matter what somebody else may be sunny
tied or
a whimsical tide and that's just a silly
metaphor of course but
that's the way i thought about it all
right then how do i market that i want
casting directors to know
exactly what they get if they cast me
now
i have active friends who say oh dude
that's very reductionist you know
you know you should be more broad-based
i don't think so i think people are so
extremely busy
that they only have time to know one
thing about you
one thing and so i gave them that one
thing and made it consistent
all across the web without the web i
wouldn't be working
most of what an actor can do for
themselves is free it just takes time
and imagination i read online that you
have this great quote that says
entertain people and they won't hit you
that's right
if you entertain people they will not
hit you it's very true
where does that come from uh it comes
from being a fat kid with bad acne you
knew all the answers in sunday school
was a and couldn't throw a
football
in south carolina so all of those things
together may be the most unpopular of
unpopular kids and i got picked on every
day
and one day these kids were really
picking on me and i did this impression
of our principal who sounded like he was
120 years old
and i did this impression of him on the
intercom and they laughed and they
didn't hit me
and i thought aha entertain people they
don't hit you so that put me on the path
my whole career has been
saying please don't hit me have you seen
any of these
people now that you used to know back
and forth yeah they're all on facebook
you know how that is everybody in third
grade contacts you on facebook
right and now they're all friendly yeah
they're friendly on facebook
okay yeah they're fine hey bill way to
go great you know
you can't hold on to that childhood
wounded stuff for
very long without looking ridiculous you
know if you're 45 years old and still
talking about how
oh how hurt you were as a kid you know
for god's sake let it go
it's cute when you're 20 but you got to
let it go but still it does shell
help shape who you are right and i've
always wondered about that too
because i grew up and experienced
teasing
do you think that it how do you think it
affects people
that maybe they were just sort of the
one that blended in in the background
and nothing ever happened to them
but they never sort of raised above a
certain mark how do you think
it affects i'm probably saying this the
wrong way
what do you think it does to someone to
be in that situation versus the one that
was the popular one in school
makes you strong i speak to school kids
a lot and i tell the kids
if you are picked on and you are
unpopular and people make fun of you and
blessed are you happy are you to be
envied or you you're in a really good
position because
life is a series of things that knock
you down and i ask the kids i say
when you get knocked down what do you do
and all the weird ugly kids say
get back up and the other kids just
stare at me blankly with their beautiful
eyes
and and i tell them the beautiful people
and the people who are always told that
they're wonderful
when they get knocked they just lay on
their ass and wait for somebody to pick
them up because that's what mommy and
daddy and teachers and everybody else
always has because they're beautiful
when they get out in the world ain't
nobody gonna care you get knocked down
in the world people walk over you they
don't care
but the tough kids the kids who grew up
that way
they know how to get back up so i i
think it's a good thing
wow that's great and so you speak to
kids on
what do you work with teachers or how do
you do i used to tour to schools
as part of my work on the east coast i
would go do these workshops
artists in residencies where you do
performances and teach the kids
about whoever you were performing i
played historical characters
and so i still go out and speak to
schools whenever i can because kids are
interested in what it's like to be an
actor now all they want to hear about
with me is the horror stuff
i could talk for days about a hallmark
movie that i did
but if i say him on a thousand ways to
die dude you were the one who ate that
rabies you ain't the squirrel oh my god
was that real rabies they love that
stuff
that's all they want to talk about it's
the scary stuff and so i tell them that
no it was alka-seltzer
way too much alka-seltzer yeah
so what do you tell to those kids that
maybe you're bullied what do you what's
your advice to
them i tell them that this is what life
is
life will knock you down and you have to
make a decision am i going to get back
up or not i tell them that god has given
you a gift
there's a reason you're here you're not
here just to breathe you're not here
just to take up space
you're not here to have sex or or to
have buy cars
or to become famous all of that's a lie
it's all a lie and it's a vicious evil
lie and it's a hurtful life for kids i
think
you're here to give whatever gift you
have back to the world
develop your gift the best you can the
thing that you're most passionate about
that should be your occupation give it
back to the world
and you'll have a happy life the only
happy people i've ever met in my life
are the ones who do what they love for a
living
the rest of them are just miserable
male and female
and who wants to be around somebody like
that you know so i'm not
rich but i get to get up every morning
and at least have the possibility of
doing what i love for a living
and that's incredibly liberating i think
we all have a vocation if you can make
your vocation your occupation
you've got the possibility for a happy
life so that's what i tell kids
and then they want to hear about the
horror movies but maybe they listen a
little
so are there ever times when you've
questioned should i begin a 40-hour week
job
is there a plan b no there can't be a
plan b at least not for me if there's a
plan b i'll go to plan b
i i had to i've been a working actor for
16 years now
12 on stage 3 and a half here in la and
i haven't had a day job because
at least for me if i don't cut the
moorings and just say that's it this is
my profession
i'll either make it or i won't then i
won't do it
and so what motivates me to get up in
the morning and spend 10 to 12 hours on
social media
and work a 14-hour day doing nothing but
sitting in front of the damn computer
trying to figure out how to market
myself
what motivates me is the the need to eat
and that's good that's really good
because if i did this as a hobby that's
exactly what it would be a hobby
like michael caine who'll keep going
back to because he wrote the best book
on film acting ever
michael caine said if you're going to
make it in film it cannot be
just a full-time job it has to be a
full-time obsession
and that's that's what it is it has to
be
that's great was there ever a time you
were close to quitting
yes in the first couple of years before
i sort of found my brand and what i
what i did well on camera there were
times when i couldn't afford the peanut
butter
well i had to decide between crunchy
peanut butter and the smooth peanut
butter and do i get bread to go with it
or can i just spoon it
that kind of a thing um yeah it was
really really tough
it was brutal but because i cut the
moorings i got nothing to go back to
this is what i do for a living this is
all i know how to do
i don't know how to do anything else and
i know i can do it on the stage and make
a good living on stage but i didn't want
to go back to stage
so just fought on pressed on
prayed called my people back home and
asked for encouragement
keep on keep on i think for an actor
trying to make an
la you can't have some long-term plan
and say if i don't make it in six months
i won't make it
it's day to day because here in la the
magic thing is
at any time the phone can ring and it
can be something
wonderful and that's not true
anywhere else in the country for a film
actor
this is it what do those 12 hours entail
that you're in front of that computer
what what are you starting your day off
with what are you doing what do you wake
up do you get to emails first
um i need to do push-ups first
i need to so i force myself before i can
have coffee i got to do my 50 diamond
push-ups
then i can sit down because if i don't
do that if i just sit down in front of
the computer that's it it's done
then i'll sit down with a coffee
essential emails first
oh my god the emails do you get too many
emails
yeah how can we reverse this it's
horrible
but there are some important ones in
there sure sure so do them then i got
about 14 social media sites that i'm on
so i got to go to each
one of them and do whatever has it's
just the daily maintenance a new post
i try to have a message of the day that
cuts across all social media
i try to make it include a link then
i'll do a google search on myself i've
got google searches for about 15
variations on me
uh billo burst ugly bill over skin
billow burst creepy
uh delivery sector blah blah blah blah
you find all kinds of links from all
over the world because foreign sites
pick up stuff off imbd and put it on
can i exploit those links is there some
way i can work this what's the angle
so then by about 10 o'clock in the
morning i've got a list of about
seven different avenues of things that
could be the message of the day
and by noon i need to have that message
defined have the link and start
spreading it across all the media
so then i do that then i go back to
email and then just lather rinse repeat
and in the
in the middle of that every day i try to
do three or four
cold contacts with directors or
producers
and more so producers because a producer
told me a year ago and it really hit me
he said nobody respects us nobody ever
contacts us
nobody gives us the credit that was due
us for helping to make this picture
possible
so when i see a project i'm interested
in i write to the producers first
and if they can get excited about me
they will contact the director
and then in between all of that you know
there's the standard submissions
that you do and the standard auditions
and then you look up and it's time for
bed and you haven't left the house
do you rest on your manager or agent
finding your work or you're also
no absolutely not and and every
younger actor who's asked me number one
i said what the hell do i know
you know i'm just trying to make it
myself i'm just another working actor
but if you want advice
forget you have an agent forget you have
a manager find your own work if they
find you work it's grading
but until you're to the level where you
don't really need them they're not going
to be able to help you
nobody's going to take you under their
wing and care about you and make your
career you do that yourself
if you're not willing to do it go home
this is a
very brutal town and it has
no there's no spot here
for people who want to be cuddled maybe
i'm too german
no i agree so how do we stay
safe in our minds how do we deal with
the fact that it is a very very tough
town
and and not lose our sanity basically
and not
become hardened and bitter this is why
of the hundreds of thousands of actors
who are in la
you see the same ones at auditions over
and over again and i know this is true
for you too karen
you're right you see you see the same
people it's because there's a very small
pool of people
who can do this it's a heartbreaking
business it's full of rejection
people say oh you know should i come to
l.a no don't
unless you feel that you must like
there's a preacher when i was a kid and
i remember asking him you know why you
preach
and he said boy preaching ran after me
and i ran from it but it caught me so i
preached
and i think that's it if you have the
passion for it
that you can't do anything else with
your life and be happy then you can
probably make it
if you just want to be famous good luck
that's interesting because now we have
reality tv
where it's prey it's it's considered
good to have
public meltdowns on camera yeah
i know what you're asking oh okay go
ahead um well i mean what do i know i'm
nobody from nowhere you know so i'm just
a working joe actor
but for me my job
is to help the people who like to see me
do stuff if there are any people
to help them have fun their life is
really really hard and they're not
turning to me
for my emotional trauma or for any
problems i'm having they're turning to
me because they say hey
that dude makes me smile it's fun i love
watching him
do something heinous if it's a horror
movie or being weird
if it's another movie i like watching
him it's fun
and i can't violate that trust by saying
excuse me i i can't let you have fun
right now because i'm going through
something
that's not my job if i'm a plumber
i better come in and work on your pipes
not come in and tell you that me and my
wife are having a fight at breakfast
you don't care you didn't hire me for
that so the audience is my boss
and i have to give them what they are
expecting when they buy me or that trust
is violated and they're not buying any
more
for me that's that's what an actor's job
is and i think that's where old
hollywood had it right
people went to see a jimmy cagney
picture they knew why and they knew what
they were getting
my grandmother started smoking because
joan crawford smoked on screen
it's how strong the influences were
because she was a little heavyset
and she went to see this movie and joan
crawford was there and
she was a shop girl of course she's
always a shop girl and she lit up
and they asked her character they said
why do you smoke like that and she said
it keeps me thin so then i started
smoking that day
and she loved you and golfer because she
identified whether she's a tough shop
girl
i think that's what you have to give
people what they expect from you and
what helps them to have fun
we're entertainers how did you become so
resourceful
in building bill incorporated baby needs
shoes
what are you going to do you know that's
what that's why i'm
at least for me the important thing was
cut the ties no day job nothing else do
you make it
don't delude yourself if you can't make
it as an actor
go work at the quick stop do something
else but don't pretend that one day i'm
going to make it as an actor make it or
don't make it
that's my theory it's the only thing
that's worked for me have you always had
this
sort of tough love perspective or or
matter of fact
in the way of getting yourself out there
and dealing with rejection
or did this come over time through
getting knocked down and having to learn
to get back up
i've never known anything else than
being
picked on or being felt odd or being
excluded
i was never popular i'm not an
attractive guy i've never felt
as if i fit in anywhere but luckily i
picked a profession where all of those
things are assets
and not liabilities so yeah
i i love being able to
manipulate uh marketing results
i've always been fascinated by how you
can
tell people what a product is
and if you do it correctly they will
believe it and purchase the product i
find that
fascinating endlessly so my little
marketing brain is
always thinking what can i do what can i
do what can i do what can i do new
avenues new avenues
take this lollipop came out in germany
on german television
and so i thought i wonder if i could get
some german producers or distributors
interested in me because
it was very popular in germany and so i
sent them a link
from youtube of a german site called
their spiegel tv and they were talking
in german about austin
so texas wrote my little cover letter in
german using google google translate
and wrote to about 13 distributors
and i got a nice bite from a pretty big
german distributor of horror movies
and they want to talk to me about doing
a development deal
based on you know the strength of to
take this lollipop thing not the same
character but doing some horror movies
with me
and that was just because i thought how
can i
make this work for me and exploit this
it was all free it cost nothing
how do you manipulate google search
and and what does that mean to go wide
like what exactly are you doing like
that
you can manipulate google search results
uh by having multiple instances of
whatever
search result you want across the web
you want to have the same message and
the same keywords in in
metadata if possible within the website
in your own website certainly
but across the every interview that you
do every
piece of pr you put out have those same
keywords that you want associated with
it
google image search results are very
easy to manipulate you need to have the
right pixel size at least 500 pixels
wide
you need to have an alt within there if
there's an alt tag 500 pixels wide if
you can put the name
on the picture that's even better but
you don't have to it's going to pick it
up the spider is going to look for the
alt tag first
the size second and then multiple
instances of that image
across the web it's this is where you
sit there in your pajamas for 12 hours
and you look up and it's seven o'clock
and you think my god i didn't even eat
lunch
but i manipulated google search results
which is more important i don't know i
guess it depends what industry you're in
well and then everyone thinks that
acting is so glamorous and it's walking
the red carpet all this
but this this is what it really is do
you think a lot of people have
in them those things to sit behind that
computer
and to do a lot of very boring dull work
with no interaction from other people
except a computerized message back and
forth i don't know i mean i i
yeah i wish that i had come to hollywood
before i was born
in the days when you actually could be
discovered
but you can't now and this is what you
have to do you have to build yourself
before anybody's going to be interested
in you and if you don't have the
resilience to do that then
you know you don't people call you from
back home and from other places and they
say what are you doing
they're working oh you're on set no in
front of the computer
oh you're playing in front of the
computer they have no idea and you can't
describe to them because they get bored
when you talk about the intricacies of
html tags they don't care
but if an actor is not really really
really computer savvy like these two
sides of your brain are many actors
oh you know i i just want to act i just
want to act baby you can't act unless
you market
you've got to do both so you have your
marketing head on and then when it's
time to turn that off
close that file open up your performing
brain and maybe this came from years of
touring theater
where i actually had to load in props
and set up sound and do sound checks
and then realize oh my god now i
actually have to do the show too
and tear it down and drive to the next
town so you compartmentalize things
it helps to be a little nuts well we
hear this from a lot of the actor
friends that we know
that oh i i don't want to do i don't
have a youtube channel i don't want to
deal with all those other crazy no you
touch people
yeah yeah i'll let my people do that for
me they have people good but they're
people i don't have people
this is my people i'm my people people
what are people
if i had people i don't think i trust
them i really don't
i want to do this myself this is my
persona my brand
i know who i am i don't want people
creating things for me because that's
not authentic it has to be a part of who
i am
so what are you doing to drum up work
when
you go through those stagnant periods
that all actors go to what do you do
to keep that phone ringing you said work
begets work work the guesswork work as
much as you possibly can
if you're not working in a dry spell and
we all hit the dry spells can you work
on a friend's project
do it keep working because the more you
work
the more people see that you're working
and they want to hire you why because
you're working
and then you get work because you're
working and it's a complete cycle don't
ever stop
working keep creating opportunities for
yourself to work but in those dry spells
you feel like you're never going to work
again and then all of a sudden the damn
burst and usually a burst because you
went ahead and worked
even if you weren't getting paid you did
something you did a favor for a friend
just keep working can you tell us that
story about old hollywood how accessible
stars were back in the day um yes the
guy who does my
head shots names jack allen dream city
photography told me he's a great story
when he was a kid
he said a lot of the stars were still
listed in the phone book and one of them
was mae west
and he actually called mae west on the
phone
and she said um what do you want i said
you know i want to meet you
come by saturday so she came he came by
saturday morning mae west apartment mae
west opens the door
all done up to the nines he never saw
her when she wasn't fully done up
and she says oh so you want to meet me
you want to meet me bad enough to do my
laundry kit
he says yes ma'am so he did maywest
laundry
this kid who rode his bike to maywest
house he got to know her became her
friend and he went with her to the
premiere of her last film sex
tech and he told me that she
never went in public without being fully
done up she had an old car
from the 30s which she kept in storage
and anytime she had to make a public
appearance the car was brought out shine
dusted repaired she was always maywest
when she stepped out in public that's
old hollywood
and it's gone of course